à
première défaite du troisième reich
quoi
à la fin de l'année 1941 la machine de
guerre allemande avait été stoppé à
seulement quelques kilomètres de moscou
où les divisions dt30 cas du maréchal
joukov rester supérieur à tout ce que la
wehrmacht aurait pu l'envoyer en réalité
le t34 était fortement aidée par la
faire là l'hiver russe en afrique du
nord rebelle avait remporté une grande
bataille de chars à sidi rezaï
mais ces voies de ravitaillement étirés
en longueur l'avait forcé à faire
demi-tour jusqu'à artelia d'où il était
parti ce qui permit aux anglais de se
couvrir tout groupe qui avait été
assiégée par l'afrika korps c'était leur
position au 1er janvier 42 romane le
renard du désert été fidèle à lui-même
pressé de repartir au combat alors quand
les ravitaillements arrivèrent fin
janvier se fit à nouveau penseurs march
à ce moment là c'est au tour des
britanniques d'être loin d'un arrière et
les panzers allemands coupes dans les
rangs de la viiie armée comme un couteau
dans du beurre robben avait été
fantassins et connaissait l'importance
des feux d'appui à la tête de ses
divisions blindées qu'il comptait sur le
soutien efficace de la luftwaffe qui en
42 étaient supérieurs à tous ceux dont
les britanniques pouvaient disposer
il croyait profondément à l'utilisation
tactique de l'aviation particulièrement
lâche tout cas ce qui correspondait bien
mieux à son style que l'artillerie et
qu'ils pouvaient apporter leurs feux
d'appui en quelques minutes plus tôt
quand meurt comme à son habitude
dirigeants ses troupes depuis l'avant re
malmené l'afrika korps à une vitesse
infernale peu soucieux de sa sécurité
personnelle jusqu'entre ghazala et bir
hakeim ou une nouvelle ligne de fond fut
établie
après avoir testé la résistance rommel
décida de ne pas commettre à nouveau
l'erreur de sa précédente offensive se
couper de ses vivres et pendant les
trois prochains mois les allemands comme
les britanniques allaient se préparer
aux batailles qui s'annonçait comme
inévitable les deux batailles connu sous
le nom de bataille d'el alamein parmi
les sharks lé prendre part au combat il
y avait le cruise adore à britannique
ces chars moyens avaient été développés
à partir du christ y ait pu engager dans
le sahara occidental entre 1941 et 1942
avec ses 40 km h de vitesse de pointe
il était plus rapide de 7 km heure que
son rival allemand le penseur 4a et son
blindage de 48 mètres était deux fois
plus épais en revanche il était très
désavantagés au terme de puissance de
feu son canon de 48 mètres n'arrivaient
pas à la cheville du 75 mm allemand et
sa vitesse et sa protection ne
permettait pas de compenser cette
faiblesse tout comme le penseur 4a et
dispose également de deux mitrailleuses
et il était manoeuvré par un équipage de
cinq hommes le bloc moteur développé 131
chevaux mais tombait souvent en panne
le plus gros défaut du cruzet d'heure
était son manque de fiabilité
si certains pensent qu'un bel engin
forcément efficace allant dans ce cas le
crusader audio est le meilleur char de
tous les temps il respirait la puissance
et la force lorsqu'il était lancé à
pleine vitesse
soulevant un nuage de poussière derrière
lui malheureusement cela concernait plus
l'apparence que la substance le crusader
avait été produit trop vite et avait été
engagée au combat avant qu'on ait pas
lier tous ses défauts il y eu plus de
pertes du fait de pannes mécaniques que
du feu de l'ennemi et sur l'impact sur
le champ de bataille est plus due aux
efforts des équipages qu'aux qualités
intrinsèques de ce char le char le plus
lourd de l'armée britannique le matilda
2 pesant 26 tonnes est connue sous le
nom de reine du désert
selon tra extrêmement efficace en 1941
41 ses 80 mm de blindage résister à la
plupart des canons antichars de l'époque
mais lorsque l'ennemi autres
easy des canons plus puissant en 1940 2
ce char relativement lent 21 km de vin
un poids mort pour ne rien arranger son
canon de 40 mm n'étaient d'aucune
efficacité contre les nouveaux blindage
adverse
et pour couronner le tout sa
construction en acier moulé ne
permettait pas le sur blindage ni
l'utilisation d'une tourelle plus grande
apte à accueillir un canon plus gros le
bâti da2 ne réussit pas le test de
longévité bien qu'il reste en 42 un
élément important de l'arsenal de la
viiie armée
le premier champ américains engagés en
europe et en afrique était le m 3 à 5 de
29 tonnes surnommé grant par les
britanniques
louez en grandes ondes par ceux ci se
charge fiable doté d'un moteur
développant 400 chevaux a permis de
rétablir l'équilibré face aux panthers 4
a notamment grâce à son blindage de 57
mm et son canon de 75 mm
le granth disposer par ailleurs d'un
canon de 37 millimètres en tourelle et
de pas moins de quatre mitrailleuses
cela n'avait pas que des avantages du
fait de la disposition de son canot
principal le m 3 à 5 devait laisser
dépasser une part importante de sa
silhouette pour pouvoir ouvrir le feu
les américains auraient sans doute
préféré une conception différente mais
leur industrie ne leur permettait pas de
construire une tourelle apte à
accueillir le canon de 75 mm le char
allemand service des bus 42 et est le
penseur 4 à rien de moins qu'une énigme
100 canons de 75 mm et est assez
puissant mais sa vitesse de pointe de 32
km heure et son blindage de 20 mm et est
tout à fait moyen
sur le papier le penseur 4a n'avait pas
un avantage significatif sur la plupart
des engins adverse mais il releva tous
les défis avec succès jusqu'en 42 grâce
à des équipages parfaitement entraînés
qui en tirer le meilleur parti de sa
vitesse sa protection et sa puissance de
feu
bien que les allemands aient eu d'autres
engins à leur disposition l'afrique du
nord comme le penseur 3 leurs canons
automoteurs et toute une gamme de
blindés le penseur 4 était le principal
chars de combat jusqu'à l'arrivée du
tigre 20 42 lors de la bataille du
tunisie dans chaque camp on consacrera
beaucoup de temps à discuter et
planifier des stratégies bien que les
britanniques en a eu plus besoin que les
allemands ces derniers ayant fait la
preuve avec leur blitz krieg et en
particulier rommel et sans talents de
stratèges de leur capacité à exécuter ce
type de mission comme on pouvait s'y
attendre
revol fille mouvement en premier en juin
à ces penseurs sont déjà en train de
fondre à nouveau servi qu'à l'armée
britannique appuyé par les imparables
choucas le premier objectif du renard du
désert et tobrouk
il était toujours perturbé de ne pas
avoir réussi à déloger les alliés de la
forteresse en 1941
cette foire aux balles étaient
déterminés et après une brève mais
intense bataille tobrouk fini par tomber
le 21 juin 40 2 donnera rebelles un
atout stratégique important la nouvelle
de la chute de tobrouk bien accueillis à
berlin en réalité hitler était si
satisfait qu'il promu rebelles au grade
de maréchal
une promotion rapide si l'on considère
que robben avait été nommé général de
corps d'armée qu'un an plus tôt
et n'allez pas encore 100 content
les penseurs ne s'arrêtèrent pas un tube
rookie continuer sur leur lancée
malgré une résistance farouche et
d'importantes pertes surtout matériels
l'afrika korps repousser l'armée
britannique
encore et encore la viiie armée
britannique se retrouve un derrière la
frontière égyptienne et benito mussolini
pensait que les penseurs de lax à les
submerger le pays se préparait à entrer
au caire en conquérant c'était prématuré
bien que les farges de rebelles semblait
inarrêtable s'enfonçant tenter plus dans
la profondeur des lignes britannique
les divisions anglais sur forcé de
rebrousser chemin jusqu'à leur position
défensive de départ à el alamein juste
au nord de katara est à peine à 100 km à
l'ouest d'alexandrie qatar est en fait
le point le plus bas du continent
africain avec une altitude de 113 mètres
au dessous du niveau de la mer
infranchissable pour les chats ils
forment une ligne de défense naturelle
pour les britanniques la défense d'el
alamein en fut facilitée car la ligne de
front était plus courte
l'as vence des allemands permis à ces
derniers de faire plus de 6000
prisonniers et la viiie armée interdite
également de nombreux matériels de
jeunes que les allemands mais ce nouveau
fonds d'or africain a établi en juillet
quarante deux permis au britannique
d'arrêter la vente des penseurs cette
avancée rapide mis à nouveau remis à la
cour de tout vivre aux et munitions les
400 panzer qui avait commencé
l'offensive n'était mettant plus que 50
cela ne semble pas l'émouvoir plus que
de raison et lança une nouvelle attaque
le 31 août
mais l'opposition avait changé le
général bernard law montgomery pris le
commandement dans le viiie armée
il y avait l'extraordinaire général
aaron alexander dans son état major
il était également important que la
force tranquille de montgomery remonte
le moral des troupes après la déroute
infligée par les penseurs de rommel
un bon moral était nécessaire le premier
ordre de montgomery était de tenir l
amène à n'importe quel prix les champs
de mines furent posées pour interdire
l'accès aux chars allemands une seule
suffisait à détruire les chenilles d'un
penseur 4
c'est ainsi que la première
confrontation entre le renard du désert
et menti allait avoir lieu à la main
l'alpha la première bataille d'el
alamein les britanniques n'étaient pas à
leur puissance maximum mais il était
toujours capable d'aligner un nombre
raisonnable de blindés contre les canons
antichars lee 50 partenaires de rôle
après un bref mais dur combat rebelles
acceptent la défaite de 7 septembre et
se replient quelques kilomètres en
arrière pour se renforcer
c'est la première défaite du renard du
désert et cela débouche sur un
changement dans le cours de la guerre
sur le territoire africain
montgomery d'un caractère tout à fait
différent de rommel
elle ne poursuit pas son ennemi après la
victoire préférant se renforcer avant
d'essayer de repousser l'afrika korps
hors d'égypte il faut noter que les
positions de l'adversaire n'avait guère
changé depuis que les britanniques
avaient établi leur ligne de défense el
alamein rom elle ne souffrait pas
seulement de sa défaite
il tomba également malades et pour la
première fois dû retourner en allemagne
pour suivre un traitement sans octobre
la viiie armée de montgomery était
prêtre dans la contre-offensive à 21h40
sort du 23 octobre 42
ce fut de 1000 pièces d'artillerie
couvrir un feu de barrage massif
précédant l'attaqué initiale des chars
et de l'infanterie
certains soldats allemands soumis à ce
déluge de feu le décrire comme un enfer
le pire qu'ils aient tu affrontes y at
il deux ans de guerre
l'africa corse privé de son illustre
chef
ces prises de court et pour une fois il
déploya pas ces penseurs au mieux pour
ne rien arranger le remplaçant de
rebelles le général george tout le décès
date d'une attaque cardiaque le 24
octobre
rommel en convalescence en autriche en
tant qu il parlait de la situation
d'afrique du nord et fonce à l'aéroport
le plus proche où il embarqua à bord de
ce reinke lâché 3 personnel spécialement
préparé il arriva sur le fond le 25
octobre lançant immédiatement le signal
j'ai repris le commandement de cette
armée rebelle s'aperçoit rapidement que
la seule action 100 c était un repli
tactique mais l'ordre d'hitler la
victoire ou la mort
lully et l'ema le peuple allemand et
moi-même suivant votre lutte héroïque en
egypte avec une confiance totale dans
votre commandement et la bravoure des
troupes allemandes italiennes qui
servent sous vos ordres
dans la présente situation vous ne
pouvez penser à autre chose que tenir et
refuser de lâcher un pouce de terrain
le renard du désert eu d'autre choix que
d'engager une bataille sanglante contre
la 7e division blindée les célèbrera du
désert les allemands lancèrent tout ce
qu'ils avaient dans la bataille pense à
artix riche tout caf milan caceres de
lourdes pertes
ne pouvant contredira d'or du führer
malgré tout le 4 novembre
robben reçu la visite du maréchal
kesselring commandant chef de la zone
sud et proposa d'expliquer à est clair
que les forces allemandes et des
submergé en le faisant comprendre que le
seul espoir de sauver l'afrika korps et
l opéra ropi tactique rebelles avaient
déjà décidé de désobéir à hitler et de
se replier les villes mais hommes
passent en premier dit-il asie grid
westphal son chef d'état-major ilker
accepta le repli mais pas avant que
l'africa corse né subi de lourdes pertes
il restait à ce jour 21 placer en état
de combattre la viiie armée put alors
utiliser ses blindés appuyés par
l'infanterie pour une plus grande
efficacité tandis que les forces de
rebelles continuent d'infliger des
pertes sévères
le repli de l'afrika korps ne fait pas
une partie de plaisir
les plans des allemands ne pouvait plus
compter sur la supériorité aérien des
choucas la longue campagne avait prélevé
son tribut est à présent c'étaient les
chasseurs et les bombardiers
britanniques qui dominait le ciel
d'égypte et de libye mais la supériorité
aérienne alliée ne suffit pas
désorganiser l'africa corse même a
découvert avec peu ou pas de protection
elle poursuivi sa route avec une
discipline de fer
l'exécution de ce repli tactique par
rommel peut-être considéré comme
brillante et l'utilisent à tous les
moyens à sa disposition pour ralentir
affaiblir les britanniques
la poursuite devenait un cauchemar pour
bordeaux mairie son artillerie n'était
pas assez mobile c'est blindé décimée
par les champs de mines et ses crusaders
souffrait de trop de pâles mais là bravo
des allemands n'étant pas illimitées
rebelles ne faisait que gagner du temps
surtout depuis que la marine britannique
permet aux renforts alliés d'arriver à
bon port il y avait un risque réel que
l'afrika korps one et anti mais
montgomery avait du respect pour rommel
il pris soin d'éviter la destruction
totale la viiie armée réussi à repousser
les allemands sur plus de 2500 km à
travers le désert d'egypte et de libye
vers la tunisie
la même distance à vol d'oiseau qu entre
new york et dallas ou londres et athènes
plus de 2500 soldats d'afrique à cordes
c'était mort au combat et 2800 avaient
été faits prisonniers lors de la
contre-offensive de montgomery rebelles
contrôlaient à présent une petite
portion de la tunisie et les
britanniques venaient d'obtenir leur
première victoire terrestre de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était la seconde bataille d'el alamein
il était clair que c'était le début de
la fin pour les allemands d'afrique du
nord les forces françaises libres les
britanniques et les américains sous le
commandement du général dwight
eisenhower débarqué au maroc et en
algérie le 8 novembre avec la ferme
intention de débarrasser l'afrique du
nord de toutes les forces de l axe est
clair fit la promesse de redonner
l'africa corse
sa puissance originelle mais lui
consacrer plus d'attention aux fins de
l'est où la situation ne s'arrangeait
pas depuis que les allemands avaient été
repoussés des portes de moscou
malgré tout la wehrmacht avaient repris
l'initiative à l'été 1942
les batailles perdues de kharkov et de
crimes et avait coûté aux soviétiques
plus de 500 mille prisonniers sans
parler de tous les morts et des blessés
et des pertes de matériel précieux
les unités de chars étaient si démuni
que le chef d'état-major de la 4ème
armée aurait déclaré nous venons juste
d'être appelé et n'avons plus quatre
chars à notre disposition les pertes
allemandes sont moindres mais le conflit
leur a coûté cher à eux aussi et hitler
l'arrangeur via il était si certains de
la victoire en 41 qu'il ait basculé
toute la productivité sur la marine et
l'armée de l'air pour vaincre
l'angleterre en janvier la production
destinée sur le la wehrmacht fut arrêté
y compris les précieux penseur mais il y
eut quelques points positifs avant la
fin de l'été hitler a compris qu'il ne
peut pas attaquer sur trois fronts en
même temps il précise ses plans pour 42
dans la directive numéro 40 tirs toutes
les forces disponibles sont concentrés
sur une seule opération dans le secteur
sud avec pour objectif de détruire
l'ennemi avant le don de façon sécurisée
les champs pétrolifères du caucase le 28
juin 40 de l'opération sol blau menant
les troupes allemandes à travers le
caucase jusqu'à stalingrad est lancée et
à nouveau le blitzkrieg est en tête du
programme l'industrie d'armement
soviétique avait fourni relance
utilisant de char t34 mais à nouveau les
généraux russes allaient connaître de
sérieuses erreurs dans le déploiement
les chars étaient utilisés en petites
unités plutôt qu'en grosse division
blindée une doctrine est passé à cette
époque
quarante huit heures après le début de
l'offensive les allemands avaient
encerclé une grande partie des forces
soviétiques effet un grand nombre de
prisonniers
les penseurs avait le champ libre à
présent et pouvait penser librement à
travers la steppe russe en moins de
quatre semaines
il avait pris le bassin du don et
avancez jusqu au fleuve staline et ses
généraux prêtent à nouveau peur pour
moscou ce qui déboucha sur un
redéploiement des troupes stationnées au
sud
libran la route de stalingrad
malheureusement pour les armées
allemandes elle souffrir à nouveau des
remous politiques
malgré l'avancée du gros de la force de
stalingrad hitler ordonna que la 4ème
armée soit détachée pour prêter main
forte à la première armée de vente
kleist pour franchir le don
mais en classe n'avait besoin d'aucune
aide il écrira plus tard la quatrième
armée aurait pu prendre stalingrad sans
combattre je n'avais besoin d'aucune
aide et cela simplement encombrer les
routes que j'empruntais l'intervention
d'hitler éviter le désastre pour les
soviétiques ils ont le temps de
redéployer leur matériel essentiel est
de se préparer à la défense de
stalingrad
les forces allemandes sont à nouveau
confrontés à des profs
d'approvisionnement avec deux divisions
de penseurs gourmande en essence et
munitions séparées l'une de l'autre et
obligé de se reposer sur un réseau
ferroviaire endommagés et des routes
dangereuses
malgré tout l'avancée allemande sur
stalingrad continuer et plus se
rapprocher plus la résistance se
durcissait la marche des penseurs fini
par stopper brusquement sans doute à
cause du célèbre ordre de staline du 28
juillet ne reculez pas d'un pas il
appela ses troupes à engager un combat
patriotique et menaça de sanctions très
dures les défaitistes et les traîtres
à la fin du mois d'août staline l'aube à
ses deux meilleurs chefs militaires le
général vassiliev ski de maréchal joukov
à la tête de la défense de stalingrad
tali g devait tenir pour empêcher les
allemands d'atteindre le nord de la
volga et de pouvoir ainsi contourner
moscou pour attaquer la capitale par
l'est ou faire mouvement dans le caucase
par un autre angle la stratégie était
simple bloquer les allemands dans un
combat sanglant et sans merci
tout un ensemble en hommes et matériel
pour préparer une contre attaque
le décor est planté pour la bataille de
stalingrad
malgré le risque pour moscou le caucase
tallinn grade et ses cinq cent mille
habitants s'est vu attribuer
l'importance que sa position stratégique
ne justifié peut-être pas mais
importante ou pas la bataille de
stalingrad fut un tournant majeur dans
le cours de la guerre et la décision de
staline de tenir coûte que coûte 8 à
terme à toute conquête ultérieure par
les allemands à présent le grand allié
des soviétiques l'hiver arrive à elaph
entier allemand du tas composé à la fois
avec les blindés de l'armée rouge et le
froid dévastateur de l'hiver russe
les combattants sûrs pour conséquence de
très lourdes pertes dans chaque camp
mais alors que les soviétiques pouvait
remplacer leur effectif les lignes de
logistique allemand d'été ci est tirée
que seuls quelques troupes et
ravitaillement tout net atteindre le
franc
la cavalerie allemande et eloi des
divisions victorieuse qui déferlait sur
les plaines de russie à peine quelques
mois plus tôt ses effectifs a été
sérieusement écornée par les blindés
soviétiques des canons antichars le
froid après ce grand combat patriotique
comme l'avait qualifié joseph staline
le maréchal joukov attendait renomme
suffisante et et 34 pour l'ancien contre
offensive contre le point faible du
front allemand
ici au nord-ouest de la ville les chars
finir par arriver et le matin du 19
novembre 1942
zhukov donna l'ordre d'attaquer lançant
l'opération uranus dans un brouillard
enneigées l'été 34 soviétique
rencontrèrent une faible résistance car
la troisième armée roumaine qui tenait
cette partie du front n'avait rien de
sérieux leur opposer ce fut
l'effondrement avec de nombreuses pertes
encore plus de prisonniers
la contre-offensive rassemblés à présent
plus de 500 t 34 appuyé par l'infanterie
tandis que l'aviation a attaqué les
forces de l' axe à la fois au nord et au
sud de la ville les jardins soviétique
attaquant le nord ouest du front étaient
commandées par l'un des meilleurs chefs
de blindés de l'armée rouge le général
nicolas v routine et c'était 34
détruisirent ce qui restait de la
cavalerie allemand est clair était
furieux et concernant le commandant
allemand le général rhymes à la peine de
mort il changea d'avis par la suite le
dégradant rang de simple soldat
tandis qu'ils attaquaient au nord-ouest
une autre forces soviétiques
arrivé du sud est les deux unités
encerclèrent la sixième armée de vente
par luz et la quatrième armée du général
bottes et les bloqueurs contre
stalingrad
la situation des allemands devenait
désespéré car les était maintenant
couper de leurs renforts mais aussi de
leur ravitaillement
le général van par luz et ses collègues
voulu refaire une percée seule
alternative à une destruction totale
mais cette option ne souffrit pas à eux
ils durent se préparer à l'ancienne vous
allez devoir affronter les blindés
soviétiques avec à peine quelques pentes
sont en état de marche les paroles surf
à oust les canons antichars à
l'infanterie ne suffiront pas à
repousser des divisions entières de des
34 commandes et efficacement
surtout avec peu de munitions de
ravitaillement
là
la raison de cette situation fut que gow
ring avait assuré que sa lutte sera feu
pourrait maintenir un ravitaillement
suffisant pour la sixième armée
en vertu de quoi hitler avait ordonné un
porte parole de tenir
mais la luftwaffe ne plus soutenir le
rythme imposé par goering et le pont
aérien n'arriva pas livré les 300 tonnes
de ravitaillement que les deux cent
mille hommes de la wehrmacht consommé
chaque jour et ce malgré la bravoure la
détermination dont ont fait preuve les
équipages cela n'arrangera pas la
situation des forces de l' axe car
celles ci ne pourraient plus compter sur
un appui aérien
à présent les chasseurs et bombardiers
russes dominé les cieux et ravagé les
rangs ennemis
les allemands sous pression mire tous
leurs moyens pour contenir la déferlante
soviétique
les chaînes de montage de t34
fonctionner en continu et ceci harcelé
sans relâche les défenses allemandes
finalement iter décida de renforcer
stalingrad par la voie terrestre
ils envoyaient le groupement place sur
le dow ont commandé par le général von
manstein pour aider vendent pas où nous
une mission impossible aux formes
einstein et ses hommes qui n'a penseront
jamais avoir de 30 kilomètres de leurs
camarades piéger et devront abandonner
leurs tentatives de sauvetage une fois
encore les penseurs seront dépassés en
manoeuvrabilité puissance de feu dans
l'été 34 et les bété 5 soviétique à
nouveau les allemands souffrent d'
horribles perte aussi bien dus au froid
qu'à l'ennemi ils doivent maintenant se
battre rue par rue maison par maison
dans la ville assiégée
malgré tout c'est un combat de david
contre goliath de l'infanterie mal
équipés contre les meilleurs chars
disponible sur tous les fronts
pire encore les blindés soviétiques sont
appuyés par une artillerie efficacement
positionner sur tous les points
stratégiques autour de stalingrad et eux
ne sont pas à court de munitions
l'issue de la bataille de stalingrad
était inéluctable et a basculé dès le
départ avec la contre-offensive
soviétique
finalement le 2 février 43 vang pao luz
qui venait juste d'être promu maréchal
se rend au commandant soviétique
la défaite et total ainsi que
l'humiliation payé au prix fort avec 120
mille blessés et 91 mille prisonniers
dans 24 généraux trois divisions de
passeurs sont également hors de combat
la quatorzième la 16e et la 24e un coup
très dur pour l'effort de guerre
allemand
c'est un maréchal vente par lous dégoûté
qui se rend aux officier soviétique
reste de la fierté de l'officier
prussien qui doit mettre en partage et
le sort de ses troupes en captivité
vente par luce est également conscient
du fait que les nombreuses victimes
civiles ont enragé les soviétiques et
qu'ils ne peut attendre aucune dans une
chance pour lui et ses hommes
la bataille de stalingrad marque un
tournant décisif dans le cours de la
guerre
c'est le début de la reconquête de leur
pays par les soviétiques
ce fut l'une des batailles les plus durs
les plus coûteuses en vies humaines que
l'on ait jamais vu
le débarquement allié en afrique du nord
nom de code acrobates des bars louis
novembre 40 2 il est constitué trois
task force totalisant 100 7000 hommes le
général george patton commandant la
taskforce ouest est sur les rangs pour
aller au contact et se mesurer à erwin
rommel patton qui ne perd pas son temps
mais latente à profit pour galvaniser
ses hommes
soldats et marins nous ne savons pas si
les forces françaises vont se poser à
notre offensive mais toute résistance
doit être détruite
toutefois tient combattants français se
rend traités avec respect dû au co2
d'honneur souvenez vous les français ne
sont ni des nazis ni les lacaunais
d'ascq force est commandée par le
général rider est prévenu par signaux
lumineux que les français seront
coopératif et à 7 heures du matin
toute résistance a cessé dans alger à
oran les forces sous les ordres du
général frais de nadal débarque sur les
plages et par voie aérienne pour
sécuriser les importants aérodrome à
nouveau presque sans résistance un début
facile pour commencer une campagne d'un
résultat la confrontation entre 3d plus
extraordinaire tacticien de la seconde
guerre mondiale rommel montgomery et
patton
dans les semaines suivant ces
débarquements autant les alliés que les
forces de l' axe feront le plein de
ravitaillement rideau renforts se tenant
prêt pour la bataille de tunisie qui
donnera son vainqueur le contrôle de
toute l'afrique du nord
après avoir mis au point leur stratégie
et quelques accrochages entre alliés
allemands
les plans sont tracées
ici au nord-ouest de la tunisie se
trouve la première armée britannique
directement l'ouest se trouve les
français et on sud ouest les américains
au sud une petite unité française vient
d'achever une marche harassante
historique de 2500 kilomètres pour venir
prendre sa position sur le flanc gauche
de l'inviter à barbe et britannique qui
fait face à la ligne m'arrête diarrhée
laquelle rob huff s'est retranché après
son lourd hôpital alamein
la zone située en face des alliés
grouille d'allemands acheminer d'italia
raison de plus de 1000 par jour
sans parler des réserves plus de quinze
division complète à la disposition du
renard du désert des troupes aguerries
avec les équipements les plus modernes
notamment le nouveau char allemand tibre
le tigre fut le plus connu le plus
redouté des chars allemands d'un
deuxième guerre mondiale
en développement depuis le début de la
guerre sa mise au point avait été longue
bien que les coups de boutoir
administrée par les 34 en 1941 et
débouché sur l'impérative d'un nouveau
char plus pis en accélérant la
production du tigre qui eut son baptême
du feu en 42 sur le front russe
son blindage 200 mm 100 canons de 88 mm
propulsé les allemands loin devant les
soviétiques et bien plus encore devant
les britanniques qui furent confrontés
les premiers aux tigres en tunisie est
écrasé par ce géant de 56 tonnes mais le
développement la production et ratures
des conséquences le titre souffre et de
pannes fréquentes
sa grande taille le rendait difficile à
manoeuvrer l'affublant passage du surnom
assez peu flatteur de camions de meubles
le tigre pouvait détruire pratiquement
n'importe quel char alliés et ses 43 km
h de vitesse de pointe était raisonnable
mais des difficultés techniques un
mauvais entretien le laissait souvent
isolés la plupart du temps lors des
replis tactiques
en dehors de ces défauts les plus
évidents le tigre est un char unique
incorporant des nouveautés intéressantes
comme la suspension à barres de torsion
et les roues entrelacés ils pouvaient
franchir à gué de quatre mètres 30 avec
un choc lors qu'elle monte sur le moteur
un v8 mais bart développement presque
600 chevaux
le bruit de ce moteur démarre en
distance était quelque chose dans les
alliés se souviendrons avec respect oui
c'était un char mal construits menad
vers c'est effrayant lorsqu'il avait
démarré étaient en action
en parallèle du nouveau char de l'afrika
korps la luftwaffe opérant d'afrique du
nord avait reçu de nouveau bombardier
chasseurs le décor était planté pour le
batailles gigantesques comme à
stalingrad l'ordre venus de berlin était
tenait la tunisie à tout prix
rebelle ne voulait pas avoir à combattre
sur deux fronts à la fois il décida
d'attaquer les américains considérés par
les allemands comme la cible la plus
facile ainsi rommel s'enlever une épine
du pied
avant d'affronter les déserts traces de
l'inviter à l'armée britannique
les blindés allemands frappèrent ici le
14 février 43 et notre attaque eut lancé
au nord deux jours plus tard les gi's
inexpérimenté fait rapidement repoussés
et le commandant en chef des américains
en afrique du nord le général eisenhower
envoya le général patton faire le
travail qu aucun autre général américain
ne pouvait faire reprendre en main les
troupes qui avaient paniqué alors
qu'elle subissait le blitzkrieg pour la
première fois pataude rempli sa mission
en imposant une discipline de fer aux
gi's trop décontracté et restera la
ligne de front à son état initial avant
l'offensive allemande en seulement
quelques jours
alors que la bataille de tunisie
s'approche les deux adversaires
continuent de préparer le combat à
l'endroit aussi pions et hannibal ont
jadis combattu et où par le passé de
grands armés ont été détruites
après son bref combat contre les
américains
romain lancent une attaque sur les
marais où les tigres font leur
apparition et où les britanniques
introduisent un nouveau canon antichar
de 17 livres
ce canon antichar tombe à pic et pas
moins de cinquante deux chars tigres
sont détruits une grosse perte pour
robben qui voit l'initiative passé aux
alliés c'est au tour de monde au mérite
sa huitième armée de frapper à partir du
sud et d'utiliser les bombardiers pour
24 heures d'opération intense philo dans
les défenses allemandes
mango mairie avait planifié cette
bataille trois mois plus tôt son
intention était de frapper au clair de
lune contre la ligne mares tout en
contournant par la gauche avec des
blindés légers le but étant de créer une
brèche sans laisser le temps rommel de
réunir des renforts
les trois jours depuis précédent
l'offensive ont transformé le terrain
d'un champ de boue il devint raisonnable
de commencer par là tirs de barrage
d'artillerie pendant la nuit suivie d'un
assaut d'infanterie
juste avant de lancer les blindés qui
pourraient être handicapés par le
terrain difficile pour permettre aux
chars lourds de progresser dans la boue
les fantassins en place et des fagots de
bois leur passage cette technique a été
utilisée pour la première fois quand les
chars ont fait leur apparition pendant
la première guerre mondiale
principalement pour permettre aux chars
de franchir les tranchées
après une nuit de combats intenses avec
de lourdes pertes dans chaque camp
j'invite la barbe et la russie qu'à
établir une petite tête de pau avec
quatre chars rebelles retire à
quelques-uns de ces penseurs d'autres
secteurs pour repousser les britanniques
la perte de 52 tigre devenait un sérieux
problème
le contournement par les alliés lancé à
pleine vitesse
karl est primordial de couper les
allemands de leur ravitaillement
l'attaqué dirigée par le général
freiberga essai néo-zélandais renforcée
par la 1re division blindée appuyée par
des bombardiers autres avions d'appui
antichars
les forces aux allemands sont maintenant
prises au piège car elles ont fait
mouvement beaucoup trop tard avec un
effort déterminer les néo zélandais
brise la ligne de défense allemande et
entre sur leur position d'origine
il
les troupes de rommel sont ainsi sans
cesse repoussés vers le nord et la mer
tandis que la navy pilonnent le littoral
pour tenir les renforts allemands à
distance les allemands sont piégés dans
une zone de plus en plus petit est
l'objectif des alliés de prendre un
certain nombre d'objectifs clés qui sont
le début de la fin pour l'afrika korps
et ses alliés de lax en afrique du nord
ses objectifs sur la colline 609
langston il la plaine de gobelins le
diavel mansour est accro là
les alliés attaque avec les chars
l'artillerie l'infanterie et l'appui
aérien utilisant toutes leurs ressources
disponibles
tous les objectifs sont finalement
atteint principalement grâce à la
sixième division blindée britannique qui
en fonçant sur tunis détruisit la
plupart des penseurs encore en état de
combattre la principale bataille de
chars durera trois jours et en résultat
la destruction de la majorité des
penseurs allemands assurant le succès
aux français et aux américains dans
leurs secteurs respectifs
la colline 609 et le dernier point
stratégique à tomber les alliés sont
maintenant aux portes de tunis et de
bizerte
mon dos ma vie transféra secrètement le
quatrième un dia et les 1er et 2e
division blindée de la viiie armée du
sud à la première à rueil au nord où il
était requis pour la fac principal
la roue tourne l'offensive alliée tu
habites reagan échelle que les
inventeurs de cette doctrine
particulière n'aurait jamais rêvé
infligeant de lourdes pertes aux
allemands probable rappeler à berlin par
hitler c'est le général joergensen
ramine commandant la 5ème armée qui
hérite de la défense du tunis il se bat
avec bravo aux déterminations mais les
alliés réussissent à percer leur ligne
et les réduisent à trois poches offrant
peu de résistance ils se rendent le 13
mai 1943
deux cent soixante quinze mille soldats
allemands italiens se rendirent marquant
la forme de l'africa corse et de toute
présence allemande en afrique du nord
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre la tunisie
était maintenant la plateforme à partir
de laquelle les alliés pourraient
frapper l'italie
la leçon retenir de cette campagne vous
améliorer vos armes et à chaque fois
l'adversaire développera de nouvelles
contre mesures qu'on a pu le voir avec
la confrontation entre le char tigre le
canon antichar de 17 livres
la guerre l'hivernale sur le front de
l'est ami hitler devant l'évidence que
l'allemagne pourrait lancer notre
campagne d'été et il pense sérieusement
une ligne de fortification similaire au
mur de l'atlantique que les allemands
les construit le long de la côte
française
mais le maréchal gueule tu as folk lung
le persuada que la bataille de koursk
qui n'était qu'un effet secondaire de
l'offensive soviétique de début 43
combinée à la contre-offensive de
manstein à travers la ville dort elle ne
valait pas la peine de risquer
d'encerclement la longue retraite des
allemands avait suffisamment réduit le
front pour libérer presque deux armées
mais elles durent attendre encore trois
mois faut que les chars sortent des
chaînes de montage et via les équipes et
les problèmes de jeunesse du tigre ont
été résolus on ne l'appelle plus
péjorativement le camion on lui doit
respect sans limite principalement due à
son cadre de 88 mm très efficace pour
décapiter la toile datée 34 l'expression
dit le t34 se découvre à chaque fois
qu'il croise un tir
le panther le nouveau char moyen du
troisième reich si toutefois on peut
qualifier de chars moyen d'engins de 43
tonnes et de bien des manières supérieur
aux tigres
bien qu'il souffre également du certains
problèmes de jeunesse sa transmission
peu fiables ces optiques bri dans son
excellent canon de 75 mm l'espace entre
les chenilles et la structure qui le
rend vulnérable aux armes légères et
vous explosif sur les 300 construit tous
ceux qui ont survécu la bataille de
koursk son retour leur musique pour être
modifiés malgré tout lorsqu'il fut
pleinement opérationnel le panther fut
le premier char supérieur aux t34 même
dans sa version 85
ce n'était pas tant le blindage de 75 du
thé 34 85 entre les 120 mm pour le
panther mais aussi une combinaison de
puissance de feu et de manoeuvrabilité
l'équipage de cinq hommes du panther
avait également une mitrailleuse à sa
disposition et le moteur de 630 chevaux
lui donner une vitesse de pointe de 45
km heure
la plus grande tragédie du panther d'un
point de vue allemand et qu'il n'a pu
être produit en quantité suffisante par
l'industrie allemande et seulement 5500
huit exemplaires ont quitté les chaînes
d'assemblage tandis que l'été 34 se
contient plusieurs fois seulement
des bus 43 flug avait rassemblé une
incroyable concentration d'hommes et
d'armes
neuf cent mille hommes 2700 chars et
canons automoteurs 10000 pièces
d'artillerie et plus de 2000 avions
chasseurs ou bombardier
le plan allemand prévu par le général
von manstein était simple basique la 9e
armée du général du groupement centre at
a créé par le nord l'est puis la zone
occupée de rolle et la 4ème armée de
vote
appuyé par le comte opérationnel kahn
viendrait du sud juste leur de kharkov
l'offensive allemande mais citadelle
commençant le 5 juillet mais un
excellent renseignements informa les
soviétiques et les rues syrte à mettre
en place l'une des défenses les plus
formidables jamais imaginé les deux
fronts russe du centre et de vos rose
née ici et ici
quand tu n'es plus de 1 million 300
mille hommes 3600 chars canons
automoteurs dans la nouvelle version du
thé 34 le thé 34,85 plus de vingt mille
pièces d'artillerie et de mortiers et
plus de 3000 avions
le décor est en place pour la plus
grande bataille terrestre de tous les
temps l'échelle est incroyable si les
troupes et les matériels des deux camps
étaient alignés sur une ligne celle ci
court et de los angels à houston ou de
paris à la mer noire
le général mode a laissé de forces et
les l'hymne soviétique selon la tactique
du bit ce cri le général constantine
rocco sauf qu'ils lancent une contre
attaque qui n'arrête pas les allemands
alors le chef soviétique ordonne à ses
charges sans bosser et de combattre à
partir des positions fortifiées
c'est l'une des premières fois qu'une
telle tactique est employé mais elle
sera extrêmement efficace
cette tactique a stoppé la vente de
modèles car bien que les titres en cas
de faits saint ferriol en char tigre et
panther les soviétiques ont d'excellents
canons antichars qui anéantiront plus de
400 chars lors de cette tentative de
dégagement
le 11 juillet le général mark cane popov
lance l'opération coup tout sauf une
contre attaque par cinq armées
soviétiques complète les tigres et
panther allemands vont affronter leurs
plus formidable adversaire et de loin
m
après d'intenses combats qui verront une
confrontation des chats les forces
russes réussiront finalement à percer
les lignes allemandes juste lors du
saillant d'aurel une très sérieuse
menace pèse maintenant sur les arrières
de modèles qui devra se battre sur deux
fronts où capituler le jour où
l'opération coup tout s'est fait lancer
au nord le général nicolas et valentino
sud après une semaine de combats
acharnés engagent le combat contre la
4ème armée de rock dans une grande
bataille de chat
les charlotte essaie de percer la zone
de prokhorov cas au sud de koursk et
entrent en contact inopinément avec la
5ème armée du général rapp me strophes
qui avançaient dans la direction opposée
le résultat de cette confrontation est
décrit par un témoin oculaire
cela s'est terminé en une joute soudaine
de blindés impliquant des centaines de
chats mas neuf ans dans une étroite
bande de terrain entre la rivière sel et
la voie ferrée comme les pentes ce ssd à
auxerre avait repris l'aventage remis
strophes revin au contact en une charge
de cavalerie furieuse et très rapide
l'été 34 dévalant la pente en une
reconstitution cauchemardesque et
mécanisée de la charge de balaclava
perçant le premier échelon allemande
entier et je tends la confusion dans la
bataille bien qu'ils furent surclassé
par les incroyables qu'il l'était 34 se
rapprochèrent est utilisé en leur canon
de 76 mm dévastateur à courte portée
les chats redevenant littéralement river
les uns aux autres c'est détruisant
mutuellement ou bien explosant
séparément des tourelles entier a
projeté dans l'isère retombant au pij et
remettre des épaves
lors de cet épisode particulier de la
bataille de koursk les allemands
dernière plus de 300 penseur dont 70
précieux tirs en plus des milliers de
tués et blessés
bien que la moitié de l'armée de romy
strophes est également été détruites
la balance penchait toujours en faveur
des soviétiques qui pouvaient toujours
en vie des renforts là où les allemands
on était incapable
au nord près du seigneur d'aurel les
forces de popov sont toujours en train
de combattre les penseurs de mode mais
d'autres événements joueront un rôle
majeur dans l'issue de la guerre sur le
front russe après la défaite de l'africa
corse en tunisie
les alliances opérations au ski pour
débarquer en sicile
après avoir subi de lourdes pertes en
afrique du nord éclair dans ma tante
transférer plusieurs divisions en italie
et ne peut ainsi envoyer en union
soviétique les renforts demandés par son
oncle où les passeurs de mots knights
ont repoussé sans relâche et la ville
dort elle est reprise par les
soviétiques le 5 août la situation sud
n'est guère plus brillante
le groupement sud est repoussé au delà
de kharkov le 23 août la ligne de fond
du 4 juillet s'est significativement
altérer les allemands nés en russie qu'à
créer une petite poche de résistance à
koursk et la contre attaque soviétique
ayant croqué celle doral et repousse les
allemands plus de 80 kilomètres au delà
du don est dupe celle des allemands ont
perdu plus de cent mille hommes et les
précieuses par acer division ont subi
d'énormes pertes matérielles et aussi
perdu l'initiative sur le front de l'est
il est clair continue de la force
militaire de l'allemagne à ce stade de
la guerre que cette défaite due à la
première campagne d'été était
irrémédiable
bien que les tigres et les panthères est
due à un avantage technique sur l'été
34,85 les ennemis avaient retenu la
leçon et déployant présent leurs blindés
avaient la même efficacité impitoyable
que les allemands
la défaite de l'allemagne dans tunisie
et la bataille de koursk en union
soviétique mais en l'axant sur la
supériorité des chats mais c'est
également ce tournant dans la guerre
qu'ils entament alors à de la
statistique